enfin le grand jour les derniers
candidats du concours voie d outre mer
sont à paris pour la finale
ils étaient 150 ils ne sont plus que
huit comme alix qui vient de martinique
dans la salle pour l'encourager fabrice
di falco
l'artiste lyrique est à l'initiative de
ce concours sont ces conseils qui nous
ont menés jusqu'ici
déjà qu'ils nous ont permis de
développer en fait dû jouer nous a
repérés lors des auditions jusqu'à l'
jusqu'à ce moment fatidique en fait on a
tellement travaillé on a tellement
comment dirais je bossais sur le
répertoire sur le programme sur les
voies aussi bien des voix complètement
professionnels qui sont du cnsm que dit
comme des voix complètement autodidacte
comme alix ou d'autres candidats
d'autres candidats comme livia elle n'a
que 15 ans et déjà une voix cristalline
elle appréhende un peu d'être seul sur
scène mais fabrice et la martinique
ainsi que ses parents venus spécialement
de martinique
ils ont visité la martinique it ont
entendu je me sens un peu stressé
maintenant avec toute la bienveillance
de fabrice on est totalement détendu et
on se dit que on n'est pas là pour
gagner un concours mais on est là pour
pouvoir chanter librement et être aimé
ce qu'on fait
la finale a lieu en public se sont
présenté des candidats autodidacte
sélectionnés en martinique et en
guadeloupe notamment sur scène aussi des
chanteurs confirmés comme la
réunionnaise clarabelle ont bien eu les
faveurs du public
[Musique]
marie laure garnier originaire de guyane
c'est elle qui a été choisie par le jury
pour être la grande gagnante du concours
voie d outre-mer je suis très heureuse
d'avoir reçu ce prix
tu es très heureux d'avoir défendu les
couleurs de la guyane et plus
généralement les portes des autres
maires livia reçu le prix jeune talent
andreas et coup de coeur du jury
ils recevront une formation pour
préparer leur entrée au conservatoire
[Applaudissements]